if you're looking for ways to find your
motivation optimize your working
environment and get work done then this
video is for you don't do this big think
different don't do these big innovation
thing screw that it's meaningless even
though I'm a geek I actually really
enjoy the social interaction
I enjoy cursing at people when they make
mistakes
it's said at a very slow speed I call in
my zombie shuffling desk need motivation
watch it top ten will believe nation
what's up it's Ivan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
in that amazing thing you have inside
you that I want to see burst out into
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and have you believing in you
grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who went from being named
after a Nobel Prize winning scientist to
being the principal developer of Linux
he's leanest Torvalds and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one get the work done I'm a huge
believer in just the 99% sweat
1% oh well what 99% perspiration 1%
inspiration I think any technology
project the innovation that this
industry talks about so much is bull
innovation anybody can innovate don't
don't do this big think different don't
do these big innovation thing screw that
it's meaningless like the 99% of it is
get the work done right and and there
are I actually that's my least favorite
part of the technology like news cycle
is this constant innovation new ideas
and this will revolutionize all that
hype is is that's not where the real
work is yeah the real work is in the
details and I'm obviously one of those
people who just I like to concentrate on
one project I don't like flitting from
one idea to another and and you need the
people who just flutter about and come
up with ideas but they're not the really
useful ones they're the wanna see who
they end up being the ones this
evacuation so I guess the people who
then do the work I love this message and
so often you hear people say you got to
work smart you got to work smart yeah
you got to work smart but you also have
to work hard
anybody who's achieved anything at the
top they were insanely hard as well as
working smart to get there
great point I love it kicking this off
number one let's get to number two do
not let go you mentioned that you've
been programming since you had like 10
or 11 off your life were you this sort
of computer genius you know you Bernard
were you the star at school
do everything and what what were you
like as a kid yeah I think I was the
prototypical nerd I mean I was I was not
a people person back then that's my
younger brother I was clearly more
interested in the Rubik's Cube that my
younger brother right I was a geek I was
into computers I was into math I was
into physics I was good at that I owe
him I don't think I was particularly
exceptional apparently my sister said
that my Vegas exceptional quality was
that I would not let go right now I
would just okay so let's let's go that
cuz that's interesting you would not let
go so so that's not about being a geek
and being smart that's about being
stubborn that's not being stubborn
that's what like just saying starting
something and not saying okay I'm done
let's do something else look shiny and I
noticed that in many other parts in in
my life too that I lived in Silicon
Valley for seven years and I worked for
the same company in Silicon Valley for
the whole time that is unheard of right
that's not how Silicon Valley works the
whole point of Silicon Valley is that
people jump between jobs to kind of mix
up the pot and and it's not the kind of
person I am another super important
point and you'll see it across all the
successful entrepreneurs the consistency
the dependability the reliability every
day just getting up and doing it you'll
have people who are less smart less
talented less capable who win because
they just are more consistent and they
show up every single day compared to the
people who might be geniuses might have
great ideas but they don't do anything
on it love it okay rule number three
have passion having vision maybe what
gets you past the problem my argument
has all often been that if you like look
at the stars all the time you will
stumble over the pothole in the ground
because you're not looking where you're
walking
Billy Maureen having passion I think
really caring about what you do is way
more important than than having this
mental vision of this golden future that
you want to reach and this is another
one that guys comes up over and over and
over again you have to have passion you
have to love the work you have to love
the process yes have a big goal for
where you want to go and enjoy the daily
work of what you're actually doing
that's it be successful
next rule number four start small the
most important thing you should keep in
mind when building something new is to
not think you're gonna change the world
and not over design and not make it
something huge and big and completely
different from what has gone before it's
it's nice to think that somebody has one
great big idea and will apply that idea
to make the world a better place and
that's not how the world actually works
every I mean I've been involved in many
projects but all of them have started
from very pedestrian routes trying to
solve a particular problem I had and
some of them never got any further but
the successful ones when I had solved my
problem somebody else came around and
said hey that almost solves my problem
too and and they grew from the fact that
it they started small but the roots and
the basics were good enough that they
could grow but don't try to aim for the
moon I mean I don't I did not start
Linux thinking I would take over the
world but we're almost there now so this
one is interesting I don't think there's
anything wrong with aiming for the moon
I think it can actually help you stay
motivated stay driven drive forward
every single day because you have this
guiding thing that's that's directing
you I think the most important part from
this for me is that you still need to
start
you still need to start small right it's
for me thinking big and starting small
doing something that might be really
streon every single day and that
eventually comes closer to that big
vision you have for yourself so that's
my take but let's move on to rule number
five learn through trial and error how
in addition to how do you process so
much code how do you understand what
requirements are out there what features
and functionality you want to integrate
it well I mean that's that's the real
advantage of open source I think is that
if you want to do something new
something that really is pushing the
envelope the only way you can really I
mean nobody can really say this is the
way to do it
so what what you need to do is just a
lot of trial and error and I often
compare suffer development to biological
processes where where it really is
evolution I mean it is not intelligent
design I'm there in the middle of the
thing and I can tell you it is
absolutely not intelligent design
whatever you you want to think you have
to have I mean you have a lot of people
who have their ideas of where things
need to go and then you need to have a
marketplace where you can try them out
and that's where open-source allows all
these different grooves to just go off
do their own thing and then come back
and say hey look I did this and it
actually worked I think it's really
important to learn through trial and
error I think if you look at whoever has
the most success that you look up to who
hit the biggest wins they also had the
most failures
you cannot play your life so small that
you don't even try because you're afraid
of failing you will fail you learn from
it and you get better it's a message
again it's repeated over and over and
over again let's move on to rule number
six embrace your uniqueness going back
today I'm not a people person
sometimes I'm also shall we say myopic
when it comes to other people's feelings
and that sometimes makes you say things
that hurt other people and
I'm not proud of that right but at the
same time it's I get people who tell me
that I should be nice and then when I
try to explain to them that maybe you're
nice maybe you should be more aggressive
they see that as me being not nice and
we're all what I'm trying to say is we
are different I'm not a people person
it's not something I'm particularly
proud of but it's part of me coming back
to the point where I said earlier that
always I was afraid of commercial people
taking advantage of your work it turned
out and very quickly turned out that
those commercial people were lovely
lovely people and they did all the
things that I was not at all interested
in doing and they had completely
different girls and they used
open-source in ways that I just did not
want to go but because it was
open-source they could do it and it
actually works really beautifully
together and I actually think it works
the same way you need to have the people
people that communicators that the warm
and friendly people who like really want
to hug you and get you into the
community but that's not everybody and
that's not me right I care about the
technology there are people who care
about the UI I can't do UI to save my
life I mean if I was stranded on an
island and the only way to get off that
Island was to make a pretty UI I died
there so there's different kinds of
people I love this point and I think
it's really really really important to
have the self-awareness to understand
who you are what you're great at and
spend as much time doing that as
possible you have Michael Jordan level
talent skill at something spend your
time there if you spend your time doing
all the crap that you hate and you're no
good at you're never gonna be able to
build something amazing get the people
who love doing that stuff and let them
go wild with it so you can focus on what
you are a natural genius at let's move
on to rule number seven find your
motivation what keeps me motivated is I
used to start out as a pure programmer
and actually writing the code myself and
that is still fun and I still do it on
the smaller projects but it turns out
that even though I'm a geek I actually
really enjoy the social interaction
I enjoy cursing at people when they make
mistakes I like I like the
back-and-forth I like the arguments I it
really motivates me to be part of a very
vocal community we have we have a lot of
engineers with a lot of ego and and it's
really exciting to just participate in
that so we do have technical discussions
and not all of them are cursing but that
kind of does that spice to your life so
it's still it's the communities the
people it is the communities it's the
communication yes my biggest takeaway
from this is that you get to create the
environment that you want to help you
thrive and succeed so if you want
certain kinds of people around you who
have certain values certain belief
systems certain skills certain
understandings then surround yourself
with those people if you'd like to be
isolated alone for stretches of time
then do that if you have an office that
you walk into that you're excited to see
do that
we're in clothing do that reading books
do that the thing that makes you come
alive that gets you motivated on a
consistent daily basis so you don't have
to think about it
give the wake up every day and think
about it you can actually just go into
your environment and it gets you
motivated that's when the magic starts
to happen let's keep it going to rule
number eight be brutally honest and
media has been one of the worst trouble
spot we've had with hardware
manufacturers and that is really sad
because then media tries to sell chips a
lot of chips into the Android Market and
NVIDIA has been the single worst company
we've ever dealt with so Nvidia
thank you to friends there
don't get me wrong I'm not saying that
other companies are perfect either we
have had companies that just don't care
we've had companies that felt that Linux
wasn't a big enough market we've had
we'd have situations like that at the
same time there's a lot of companies
that have been very helpful since very
early days and it's I think it's very
sad when you sell hardware and you
actually use Linux and you're being
really difficult about it
and and I really yes I'm I'm sad when it
happens we can't do anything about it
but it's life I wish everybody was as
nice as I am
I like being outrageous at times it's
it's amusing to see I guarantee you if
you make that video available on the
Internet there will be thousands of
people who are really upset and I know
an offended I like offending people
because I think people who get offended
should be offended it's like so that's
an interesting perspective and
interesting clip I think the thing that
I take away most from this is just being
yourself and if you have an idea that
you want to express it you want to share
something you have to get out then don't
just sit on it don't just wait on it
don't just worry about what other people
are gonna think or say doesn't mean you
have to necessarily go out and and
offend people just to offend people but
if there's something that's inside you
that you want to get out and something
that you might regret not doing this
idea you have that if you don't act on
it you may regret then actually just get
out there and do it and the more that
you are yourself and you express that
the more people gonna relate to you as
opposed to just thinking you're this
corporation you're this robot that they
can't connect with moving on point
number nine is create for yourself
there are whole projects that do only
source code maintenance and CVS is the
one that used to be the most commonly
used and I I hated CVS with a passion
and refused to touch it and tried
something else that was radical and
interesting and and everybody else hated
and we were in this bad spot where we
had thousands people who wanted to
participate but in many ways I was the
the kind of
break point where I could not scale to
the point where I could work on it with
thousands of people so get as my second
big project which is only created for me
to maintain my first big project right
and this is literally how I work is I
don't I don't code for well I do code
for fun but I want to code for something
meaningful so every single project I've
ever done has been something I need it
and so really both both Linux and get
kind of a rose almost as an unintended
consequence of your desire not to have
to work with too many people absolutely
yes no no that's amazing I think this is
the main reason why most entrepreneurs
fail they create a product or service or
company just trying to make money just
trying to chase an opportunity as
opposed to actually creating something
that you enjoy that you love that you
have a passion for and so when you
design something that solves a personal
problem of your own like I did for these
top ten videos I love that you guys love
them but I made it for me because I want
to be surrounded by genius and greatness
every single day I made it selfish it
for me that's why the passion comes out
and I make something hopefully amazing
every day for you guys and I'm able to
share it and so if you start with that
your own personal passion a problem that
you're face and that you desperately
want to solve then you go off and share
it with the world
that's the seeds of successful business
all right a rule number 10 the last one
is optimize your working environment so
this is my working space I've been using
a walking desk for the last three or
four months now I'm not sure how much it
does for me but I'm sure it's healthier
than just sit down I'm also trying to
keep my desk clean because if you pan
over to my old desk which I don't
actually use anymore because it cups so
filled with crap I don't know what to do
about this anymore I need to burn it
down something I used to work night
times but then I got kids and the kids
go to school and that means that we had
to wake up at
thirty or so to take the kids to school
it's not exactly a nine-to-five job but
it is actually fairly close and you can
see that in in the commit blocks it's
interesting I've sometimes do statistics
of how which time zones people are and
what what time people are working at and
these days you can definitely tell that
a lot of people are actually keeping
pretty regular hours I'm not the only
one with kids clearly it's set at a very
slow speed I call in my zombies
shuffling desk because if I put it any
faster than one mile an hour my mouse
movements get very erratic and I no
longer can close my windows so I'm a
huge fan of designing your work
environment to support you whatever that
looks like he's using the walking desk
on the treadmill I'm on a trampoline
I've been using a stand-up desk for a
number of years I love the trampoline as
an adjustment but everything from your
desk your environment what's on the
walls you know what's on your table
what's in front of you what you wear
like you want to design it again so that
when you wake up and you go to your
office instantly you're in an
environment that motivates you to want
to work hard and get hustling instead of
you having to think about it super
important understand what drives you and
then create the environment to make that
automatic for you
thank you guys for watching I would say
that rule number two do not let go is my
personal favorite I'd love to know which
one is yours and why leave it down the
comments below I'm looking forward to
hearing what you have to say I made this
video because HB asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
would like me to profile next check out
the link in description and you can go
and cast your vote on the request line
video so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
so was there a moment when you saw what
was being built and it suddenly started
taking off and you thought wait a sec
there's actually could be something huge
not just a personal project that I'm
getting nice feedback on but a kind of
an explosive development of the whole
technology world not really I mean the
big point for me really was not when it
was becoming huge it was when I was
becoming little right it the big point
for me was not being alone and having
ten maybe a hundred people being
involved that was a big point then
everything else was very gradual going
from a hundred people to a million
people is not a big deal to me well I
mean maybe it is if you're if you want
to sell your result it's a huge deal
that could be wrong but if you're
interested in the technology and you're
interested in the project the big part
was getting the community then the
community grew gradually and there's
actually not a single point where I went
like wow that just took off because it I
mean it took a long time relatively the
thing I really enjoy about programming
is just the fact that you really can
tell the computer exactly what to do and
it will do what you tell it and nothing
more I don't know maybe I'm autistic or
something
what borderline but that doesn't happen
in normal life
you see code you don't have to even
think about it you you look at something
and you know what it does if you're not
a programmer you would think it's almost
[Music]
noiseless but just doesn't actually
solve the problem which is why I'm still
trying the same project 25 years later
it is
if because it's it's hard to write good
code I'm sorry to ask this question
almost but it's something that I think
is a little bit important how do you
think it affects the culture of a
community of a project when the leader
is on that projects public mailing list
telling people in response to patch
reviews that they should be retro
actively aborted and maybe that you're
surprised that they're still alive
because they should have starved to
death when they were children because
they're too stupid to find a [ __ ] to
suck on I I agree that some people might
be put off by that but on the other hand
[Music]
you know what I in the end I don't care
right I care about technology and I've
actually seen projects that took the
whole political correctness so far that
the the project no longer is about the
technology I grew up in a culture that I
think is not quite as politically
correct as the culture especially in the
u.s. today like when I say something
like I wonder how he grew to be an adult
when he's so stupid that he I don't
expect him to find food
some people might realize that it's kind
of hyperbole and joked not I'm not I'm
not saying something that you know it's
not politically correct or whatever
although certainly I would understand if
people do say this it's more about
treating other people with respect and
maybe saying you can applaud everything
you want but I don't respect people on
this that you think they deserve a
respect there are people who think that
respect is something that should be
given and I happen to be one of the
people who perfectly happy saying no
respect should be earned and without
being earned you don't get it right it's
really that simple
not everybody agrees and that's fine to
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that means that people
with passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details